Welcome to our P data Global tutorial on
SK time the the agenda for today would
be that we first make have a general
introduction to SK time and SK learn
then we will continue
with how we can do forecasting with SK
time and then
afterwards we will show different new
features from 2022 and
2023 this includes graphical
pipelines and improved parallelization
probabilistic forecasting
benchmarking and also different
Marketplace de deployment and model
sharing feature as estimator search um
blueprints sterilizing and ml flow
integration so if you're interested in
running the notebooks um there are all
notebooks are available on in our SK
Time Project here is the link to the
repository there are read me instruction
how to run the notebooks locally and
there's also a link to binder where you
can run the notebooks in the cloud um
and then you can just try it out what we
are showing you here so let's start with
the introduction to SK time what is SK
time SK time is a library for time
series learning um
it's an
integrative framework in the time series
bace so it's implements its own
algorithms but also and provides
adapters to third party
libraries the interface is heavily
inspired from sklearn so we following
the sklearn paradigma we have a unified
interface for object and
estimators uh in a few minutes I will
show you what that means
we have a modular
design um our our estimators are
composable and with inter with
homogeneous
interfaces and yeah and we also support
visual informative pretty printing but
SK time is more than just a library SK
time is an is a welcoming community so
if you like to contribute to open source
we are always happy for new contributor
even if you are completely new to open
source software we have a new
contributors guide we have a mentoring
program and yeah you can can just join
us on Discord um just drop into our
regular meetups or follow us or LinkedIn
or just ask questions in our Discord
channel so what does unified interfaces
mean in SK learn um SK learn provide um
provides an unified
interface I mentioned that SK time is
heavily inspired by
that and this means that any estimator
basically has three steps which have to
be executed to make a prediction first
you need to instantiate your model with
the parameters you want to use then you
can fit the instance of your model to
the new data and then use the fitted
instance to predict new
data so here is a nice pictogram with a
robot we have our OBS we have our robot
that we are constructing then we have
our training data we have a model
fitting here then a fitted model and
then we can do our
prediction so how does this look like in
code um here we are importing a data set
from SK learn
we are loading these data set and then
we split these data into train and test
set the x Trin and X test are the
exogenous features and right train and
right test are the data are the target
data um here we see our the exrain data
and there we have four different
features and the iris data set is a
flower classification data set so these
different features o of these
flowers and the Y train is then
corresponding to the to the Target to to
the Target um of of the of the different
flowers so we in the end we want to
classify the different flower use
flowers using these
features um how can do can um um how is
the approach and ask get learn to do
this first we instantiate the classifier
here we use a support Vector um
classifier then we fit the classifier
using the training data and the right
train data and in the end then we can
call predict using the the features of
our test data set and then we have here
our
prediction important to note here is
that we can use all other another
classifier and we only have to change
the first step for example here we
replace the support Vector classifier
with a random forest classifier and we
only have to replace the the classif the
instantiation of the classif classifier
and then we can call fit and predict
with the same arguments to the
classifier and this will
work and yes and this is what we are
referring to the to the strategy pattern
okay um beside um fit and and pric there
are also other methods as get params for
figuring out the parameters of the used
of your used classifier for example here
the um the um the random Forest
classifier would have parameters as
number of estimators and these
parameters then can be set during
initialization
okay now let us go on to what SK time is
SK time
basically um uses the same approach as
SK learn for for time series and for
different time serious tasks for example
for forecasting for classification
regression clustering annotation and so
on some of them are more stable some of
them are are more M maturing and some of
them are still
experimental and this talk we mainly
will focus on
forecasting and since also forecasting
is probably the most widely used use
cases of SK time so what's the special
kind in Time series forecasting in Time
series
forecasting and in the simplest case we
have our time series our Target data Y
and then we want to predict the next
values of this target data
so that's the temporal forward
prediction basically the
forecasting um how can we do this within
SK time it's very similar to SK learn we
load our data and then we are
specifying how many um time steps we
want to to predict that's the
forecasting
Horizon but if you're if it's coming to
the to the for to the estimator itself
it's basically the same as for the for
SK learn we instantiate our our
forecaster call fit on it and then we
can
predict and we have here no exogeneous
features just the time Ser itself which
is passed during during the during
calling the fit and then in predict we
are specifying here how many steps in
advance should be
forecasted um and then if you blot this
then we see here
that here we have a forecast for the
next um 30 36
month in in this data set um
classification time service
classification um there it's work
similar um in Time series classification
you have multiple time series um um with
labels for training and then you want to
to
classify um the unlabel
serus and here we load again our time
series then we here specify our
classifier in this case we have a canum
neighbors time series classifier with
some
distance um which we would like to use
and so here's the in intiation and then
we again just have to call fit using the
input time series and and right train
and then we can
predict now here is to note that the
that between different task between
forecasting between
classification um the input differs in
the classification example we have here
200 instances one feature per instance
and each instance has
427 time steps and the the cloud
labels are then we have one label per
per instance so we have 200 200
instances okay
so SK time is not only implementing its
own algorithm it integrates a time
modeling ecosystem the reason is that in
in the in the time series ecosystems
there exists a lot of different packages
focusing on different Al kind of
algorithms different tasks and basically
es time also aims to provide adapters to
the different to the different libraries
for example TS fresh PDM ARA profit CLS
and so
on and basically SK time acts in this
case as a layer between the different
tasks you would like to solve and then
the algorithm you would like to
use
so what's next um now today we want to
um
to um provide you a short
forecasting um introduction this is done
by by Anan and then we will focus on new
features that are added um last year or
this year so now I will hand over to
Anan
who will present the
forecasting uh thank you Benedict uh I'm
[Music]
a yep okay so let's go on so hi everyone
so now we are going to see a basic
introduction to forecasting component of
uh SK time we have a lot of other
components in SK time focusing on time
series classification regession as
Benedict just covered obviously the most
popular use case of time data set is
forecasting and we thought we should
give a basic introduction for the people
who are new to
es uh we should start with a very common
example that is very popular in a retail
use case for example here we are going
to stti a look at sales data uh so SK
time comes with quite a few inbu data
sets uh one of the data sets is shampoo
shells uh which is available for 1991 to
1993 monthly sales data and obviously
here our goal is to predict what is
going to be the sales count in future
months to handle this problem we can
load the data from SK time data sets
import load shampoo cells and after that
we can just plot with our utility
function plot series we're going to see
multiple uses of plot series function
through different different uh number of
Time series different patterns of data
intervals Originals Etc we are going to
see this throughout this session so we
can just import plot series function and
and plot series Y is going to create
this plot so as we can see the uh x-axis
is the time stamp information that is
part of this data which is provided to
this s index which we going to see in
just few seconds and the y axis is
obviously the actual values now if we
take a look at the raw values of this
data we can see this is the format it is
a pund series with the values being the
actual sales for the sh uh shampoo sales
data and and the index is the time
information so all SK time forecasting
all Des data type format that time
supports for forecasting is going to be
very similar to this what are the
changes can happen if we consider a
multivariate data sets as opposed to a
univariate data set like this is it is
going to become from series to a data
frame and but the index will still be a
time stamp or some something that shows
you the information for time Horizon
second all the observations must always
have the time information in index as
monotone so that we have a continuous
sequence in time we do not have uh say
for example suddenly 1991 followed by
1993 and then 1992 that is not going to
be allowed but while you load the data
we have helper function so that you can
verify what is wrong and you can change
the M type and S Type
accordingly third generalization that
can happen along this is when you have a
panel data or hierarchical data so for
example in a business use case you may
have data set as say sales for store
item level so in that case it will be
the index is going to be a multi-index
the first index the first values of the
index is going to be the hierarchical
information and the last one and it will
always be also for hierarchical also for
panel the last will always be the time
information so the index type of the
last uh index should be either time
index or just date index period index or
it can also be range index as long as it
is
mon now we are going now that we are
clear on what is the expected data
formats we will go ahead with a standard
flow as we covered in the previous
notebook as well that very common step
in all uh ml problems is to split into
train and test subsets we are going to
use temporal Trend split function this
is a slight modification of uh esalon's
train test split function train test
split offers you to split the data into
train and test uh randomly obviously you
can set the seat let's not worry about
that and also you can do say
statification and Etc but in case of a
Time series you should not do a random
split because test should always come
after train the time information should
be kept into consideration for that we
have sightly modification modified the
train to split fun function and have the
trend split and we are going to see two
at least one more version of temporal
Trend split when we have exogenous
feature later in this particular use
case what you are saying is take the
original data y split it so that the
test size is six so it is going to take
the last six observation of the original
data and that is going to be considered
as the test data it is going to return a
tle again similar to Escalon and we are
getting white TR white test if we plot
the data using the same utility function
as we used last time and here we see one
different use case that instead of a
single cies we can pass multiple cies
and identify what label to use by
separate levels in the label cument and
clearly we can see in the plot the first
part of the data is the training part
and the second part is the test part and
we can also take a look at the head and
head of both train and test subsets
obviously combining train and test we
should get back the original y compet
complely now we have the entire data now
we need to do the forecasting how should
we proceed first let's take a choice of
a forecasting model let's choose
exponential smoothing we will also take
for Simplicity for now we'll also use
the auto ETS model which is basically
the hindman's modification where it
automatically determines what is the
bestas parameter of the model ER train
are they additive or multiplicative that
we will choose it now automatically and
we will see at the end how we can do uh
determine it ourselves through hyper
parameter tuning that will be the end of
this not first when initi this uh
instance this is similar to the
structure that we established already as
part of the first notebook first step we
uh initiate the estimated object
forecaster is created now we pass the
training dat set y train that we created
just before we pass that to fit
call after fit call is over forecaster
state gets changed and it now has the
fitted model and all the fitted
parameters is there now we need to
predict let's say in this example we
want to predict for next 6 months so we
are specifying 1 2 3 4 5 6 so here one
thing is to notice that in es Time Zero
is always the last point in the training
data set and so one is the next
observation in the same unit of time as
the original training data since the
original training data was monthly as
informed from the index automatically so
1 2 3 4 5 6 will mean give us a
prediction for next 6 months if required
you can also specify say 2 5 six it
doesn't need to be a continuous sequence
you can vary and if you want it can even
be like say 41 six something like that
if you want you can give negative values
for in Sample
predictions uh yeah so once you uh
specify what all uh you need forecast
for you pass that to the predict uh
method FH equal to FH and get the final
predictions uh then you can plot and we
can see here that the orange line is the
original test values and the green lines
are the predictions that is coming out
of the model predictions so it's very
much of a smoothing line which is
expected from a exponential smoothing
model and doesn't really capture too
much of the data sets we are going to
cover different algorithms later but the
main focus of today's session is the use
so we are not going to
bother too much about the fluctuation
capturing part but we will still cover
some part of it
later now since we are see you can see
that the it is not capturing fluctuation
as a business use case or any use case
we would want to know how we are doing
so we need to create uh establish a
baseline for that we need to have a
metric for the purpose of the evaluation
we are going to use the performance
metric component of esap where we have a
bunch of metrics defined for different
task classification regation forecasting
Etc obviously we are in a forecasting
use case so we are going to use the
forecasting sub component of performance
Matrix and use S map foration so we are
taking map mean absolute percentage
error metric class from the component
and we are going to initiate the metric
object with symmetric equal to True by
default um in percentage is going to
give us map without uh considering for
the symmetric so it is going can be
infinity and anything uh so that's why
we are going to switch it to symmetric
equal to true and here this smap we are
going to use it
throughout once we create the smap
object we can just pass the original and
predictions and see the errors and we
are seeing it has resulted into 16.7%
error this is our Baseline for that we
are should know two things that we have
used SM map here but as I said said we
have a bunch of uh matrics already if
you you should use multiple metrics to
see what is applicable where for example
nrmc also by hman is a very good choice
in a lot of business much more uh
appropriate than smap but that's up to
your second thing that we should notice
here we did the trend split by a single
split we split the entire data set into
just last six and everything else very
often this is not suitable you should
want to do back testing so for example
we will split the data into multiple
components uh strain on some part of it
predict again update the model that's
all we will see a example at the end
this okay so now this is the very basic
use case of forecasting now we are going
to see what all enhancements can be done
in different direction first enhancement
we are going to see is exogenous
features very often say in a business
use case you know that your variable of
interest is something but you also have
other features that affect this variable
in a standard forecasting model that you
have C exponential smoothing it doesn't
take those things but you would want to
use those effects so how they are
changing is affecting the prediction of
your variable of inter we're going to
see how es time helps you to consider
these cases for this we are going to use
the longly data set it's a standard data
set from R uh the data set here the
target variable of interet is the number
of employed people and the exogenous
features that we are going to use are us
macro economic features and based on the
data set we know that these features are
highly Cal there is a too much relation
between this and it is very often used
in other statistical purposes as well we
can take a look at how the data looks
like so you can see here why uh is to MP
and again it's the same format as we SE
in the previous data set the index shows
the time information it's this time it's
a period index and values are the actual
number of employed people in this series
uh if you scroll down below we can see
also the ex set and the different uh
features that is coming as part of it
all of them are individual time series
as well but as of now our goal is to
forecast Y and not any of this thing not
for
now and in all since also this is a past
data so we know the entire data of X for
both past and future but again it's not
going to be the case all the time
especially in real life forecasting
problem you not going to know what is
going to be the X test how do we use it
we are going to come back to that
problem in a
bit so when we have X and we also want
to train a model and use this thing we
can use the same temporal trender split
function as we used earlier this time we
are going to pass an additional argument
xal to X and the output of the function
is going to be now a tle of four with
the two additional arguments uh returns
of X train and X test these will again
be in the same type as the input X so
here x was a data frame the output is
also data frame so if we scroll down we
will see that again y train and Y test
goes back to same thing and X train and
X test or
uh combination will be the total X as we
had
earlier now we let need to see how to
use this feature again continuing the
Streamline interface that we already had
we are going the process will be same we
will first create an instance do a fit
and then we'll do the prediction so here
in this example I'm going to show two
cases first when we use exogenous
feature second we are not going to use
the exogenous feature here some of you
from statistic background may have
questioned how does edima support
exogenous feature so here edima is the
class name but it is actually the
implementation of SX which is coming out
of SE model implementation and we are
just exposing it with our uh consistent
interface so we are going to create two
uh forecaster both of Adima both the
time we are going to uh train it with
white train and try to predict for the
next four year but one time we are going
to also pass it the ex feature the
second time we are going to pass x equal
to X train now forecaster with X has the
additional information with for C
without X does not have during the
prediction we are also need to pass now
X test to predict with the second model
because uh the for all
algorithms most algorithms is going to
need the future values of exogenous
fature if they need to use that for
prediction in case you don't know again
as I said ear we'll come back to that
problem later half in this notebook so
in this particular case we have
generated two sets of prediction once we
didn't use x at all once we used X and
if we now plot the thing we can see in
this graph that the middle line the more
yellowish orange one that one is the
original whest value the green one is
the predictions where we do not use x
and the above line the Deep orange that
is the one
where uh X values are used from the plot
it definitely looks that using X
improves the forecasting performance but
obviously we can we don't have to judge
directly from the plot we can take
benefit of the smap object we created
earlier so here we are create evaluating
the both and as we can see uh the
performance improved from 5.9% to
2.8% so this is a Improvement by using X
so here's a small note that not all
forecasters in SK time supports
exogenous feature it will give you the
same interface you can still pass X but
it can it will drop the features because
the algorithm is not just capable of
handling it if you want to know which
are the estimators that supports it you
can get it using this so ignorance uh
exogenous X is a specific tag and what
are tags how do we use it we are going
to cover it as part of the fourth
notebook and France is going to talk
over that session so we can now move on
to the next section
here right so here we are going to do
coming to the second enhancements of the
quick start that we have the quick start
used a forecasting model where we are
predicting uh Y which was sales dat in
the previous also we are predicting the
unemp uh employed data set both times it
was a univarate Target feature that's
not the case always so what have how do
we use it when we
have uh when we have mult multivariate
exogenous features in that case again as
we have discussed earlier the data set
is now in the form of a data frame and
the index once again of the period index
or any sort of time
information then we can use few of the
forecast that are purely multivariate
for example V or V Max in this
particular example we are using V again
similar interface we're creating the V
object and V importing V initiating the
V forecaster object then passing that
information to fit and finally doing the
prediction and the prediction is going
to come out like this our data frame
similar format the data wi output is
also in the same format two columns
corresponding to two different series of
the input data set and the index is the
timestamp information for which the
predictions are being made so in this
particular case one thing to not is that
uh not all foraster support uh proper
multivariate forecasting uh very few of
the we can list those by using estimator
again again we will cover how this
information is stored uh in the fourth
notebook these are the four algorithm
Dynamic Factor V ver Max VM to use how
do are we capturing uh these are the one
that can use proper multivariate thing
but what happens if you want to use an
another algorithm for example ARA or
exponential spting but in this for
example in this example Theta forecaster
you can still use it the inferface is
going to be same what is going to happen
in between because these are not
inherently multivariate model what is
happening inside this is we are training
two models independently for each column
if you also consider the EXP feature
that can also happen but in this
particular example you haven't
considered that but the uh logic is the
same so in this particular example when
we pass Theta forecaster and we pass a y
that is multivariate so it's a data
frame in that case we are going to
create multiple models corresponding to
each of the columns of Y and all those
columns all those models is going to be
trained independently this in uh
training happens in parallel and how
does the paralyzation work how to
improve the performance of paralyzation
those are the things that we are going
to cover again in the fourth notebook
when we talk about the new paralyzation
improvements using different
backends yep so so far we have covered
the two main extensions of the qu start
now we're going to call talk about a
different feature before we go into the
pipeline capabilities so this is the
feature of probabilistic
forecasting so far all the predictions
that we have made we have used the
method do
predict that gives us the predictive
mean of the
distributions but a lot of the times
that is not enough we may be interested
in confidence intervals we may be
interested in the quantiles of the
distribution something like that so we
are going to take use use these methods
as well predict quantal predict interval
Etc all of these methods are applic uh
available for all the forecasters but
not all forecasters support them we can
take a look at below sometime later uh
how to identify which one supports it
but to use uh in order to use it what
you need to do is do predict interval
call that method and pass a coverage
value so here what I'm asking for is
give me the 95% coverage for uh the
prediction Horizon that was already
passed during the fitting stage and it
is going to give me in this format the
format is going to be consistent the
column index is going to be a
multi-index first the different number
of features that went in GNP and GNP dfl
then the different then the level of
coverage that we asked for 0.95 within
that lower upper in case you want
multiple coverage for example 90% 95%
the result is going to be in the same
format we are just going to get more
results and all you have to do is pass
the coverage argument as a list if you
are interested in quantiles it will be
the exact same format in predit quantel
you will then pass Alpha equal to
whatever your choice it can be a single
value or multiple values based on your
requirements now if you scroll
down
yeah so here are the forecaster that
have the capability of uh probabilistic
forecasting capability predent is a tag
that measures it we are going to cover
it later and we are going to have there
are multiple cases of it separating the
insample probabilistic prediction and
out of sample probabilistic prediction
we are not going to cover details of
that as part of this
notebook instead we are going to go into
the how do we improve our prediction
perform performances through pipelines
as part of this section we are going to
cover three sections one is how do we
use transformation pipelines for y
Target variable uh we also obviously
support for exogenous feature we are not
going to cover that in this section
we're going to cover some part of in the
second section in graphical pipeline
which Benedict is going to cover but we
are not going to cover in many details
second part is parameter estimation we
are going to come into that across this
one and finally is forecast T this is
going to cover the case where we do not
know what is the unknown values of the x
that you are going to use for the
forecast
Horizon let's start with the first
section let's consider again another
standard data set of air passengers
again we load the data and plot the data
so now we will take a look at take some
time looking at this plot from this plot
as we can see there's a clear in
increasing Trend there's also a clearly
repeating pattern so we can see there's
a seasonality and if you note at the
number of points you will notice that
it's a monthly seasonality which is
repeating every year we also notice that
as Trend
increases uh the N uh the amplitude of
season is going to is varying so the
number amount of fluctuation that is
there when the trend was lower and the
amount of fluctuation when the trend is
is not same this indic indates that the
relation between Trend and simility is
multiplicative and it's not additive
model these are all the observation that
we can gather from this plot now we need
to plan how do we focus for this the
idea will be one idea will be we can
first take a logarithm of this data set
so that will directly convert the
multiplicative model to additive model
second we can remove the seasonality
then we will have only the trend part
left which from this plot looks like
much of a linear plot predict the linear
Trend future add back seasonality and
that should add back seasonality and
then we need to do uh an inverse
transformation on the logari logarithmic
uh transformation so we need to do
exponentiation and we will get the final
forast back at our original thing now we
need to see how do we do this SK time is
going to for you a very very simple step
with just couple of lines code to do
this but let's consider the case what
happens you didn't have a SK time you
are going to do in a normal way we are
going to cover this thing first so so
that you can understand what all things
are happening in inside and then we are
going to look at the thing how SK time
makes this complicated process much
simpler so first as I said we are taking
the logarithm of the data set so this
plot directly shows that the
fluctuations in the data set is no
longer variating is variation as much as
it was in the original plot so here the
amount of gap between the high and low
in the left side and the amount of Gap
in the right side is mostly same so we
can understand that from this plot Trend
and seity are additive now it's no
longer multiplicative so one step our we
have progressed one step second step we
need to remove seasonality
for that once again we are going to take
benefit of St models and we are going to
use EST
decomposition since we have already
observed that the seasonality present in
this data set is monthly and it is
varying like changing every year so
periodicity is 12 we are going to
specify period equal to 12 duing our
seasonal decomposition and by default it
already does additive decomposition we
don't need to specify it if it was a
multiplicative we could have still
specified in the seasonal decompos call
once the decomposition is done seasonal
result object is going to give us the
trend seasonal and residual component
we're going to pick out extract the
seasonal component and remove it from
the logged SE and now we are going to
plot it this plot shows now there is no
repeating pattern that is present in
this graph so it is mostly trained plus
some noise which is always going to be
there so we done on all the planning
that we had immediately planned from the
plot only thing is left is make the
forecast since it's a linear model we
are now going to fit a linear forecaster
so we are going to use train foraster
which by default use OLS if we want we
can use any regressor but we can see
it's a linear thing so that should be
enough for us and we are going to make
for for the next one
year so as we discussed earlier FH is
going to be specified as one to 12 you
can also do by range it's the same thing
uh we support any sort of specification
any sort of sequence specification we uh
initiate the frequent uh FH and we pass
it to the foraster object that we just
created and we are getting the
prediction this prediction however is
not in the original scale of the data
this is after uh taking logorithm and de
analyzed but from the plot it looks that
the prics are very good corresponding to
the transform data set because as you
can see even for a manual prediction
this looks intuitive it's not very much
but now we need to remember how do we
convert it back to the original
scale so that's the next step so we go
on below yeah First We Take the
seasonality component that we already
created and stored in the seasonal
object we also noted the fluctuation is
constant constant it's not variation VAR
Vari much over the time so we take 12
components so that January goes to
January February goes to February and so
on and add that part to the prediction
that we just created now that we have
that thing we can just directly exponent
exponentiate it back and the get the
final predictions in the original scale
of the data set and here's the plot and
it looks much intuitive and if if we if
you just assume that the the final color
was in blue and line you will probably
not even be able to to notice that it's
not the same graph and it's a prediction
this is how a standard forecasting model
if you didn't have es time would work
like how does SK time help
us the help as is does is you do not
have to remember to all this inverse
Transformations later it is going to
take care of that for you for the steps
will be you first initiate the object
that you need to create first a lock
Transformer we are for that we are going
to import the lock Transformer of object
from the Transformations component of SK
time we have a bunch of Transformations
available in SK time we're not going to
cover all of them and also not focusing
much on the transformation component
today but here's just one of them and
but we are not restricted to SK time
Transformers if you want you can use uh
psych pre-processing Transformations uh
you can use a pandas transformation or
even you can even write your own
function transformation we support all
of them second we are going to do the
calization which is a wrapper on top of
the seasonal decompose function from
status model that we saw earlier again
we are specifying s SP equal to 12 to
say uh do decomposition with a monthly
periodicity periodicity considering 12
and by default it is taking the model to
be additive third we are initializing
the foraster object now transform Target
foraster this is the main pipeline
object which is going to help us when we
initiate that object we specify the
different steps during the forecaster
take log remove train
forecaster now when you train the data
and do a fit and then a predict call
what it is going to do is buing fit it
does exactly what we did above but
during predict it automatically runs the
inverse Transformations for the two
Transformers that is part of this
pipeline so in this particular case when
predict is being called first it is
doing the prediction on train for Custer
object then it is inverting the remove
seity part so adding back the component
third it is adding back uh the inverse
of take clux exponentiation so when you
are doing the fit predict and plotting
the values as we can see in the below
plot it's identical to the plot that we
achieved
earlier uh Benedict if you just scroll
Bel yep uh the plot is the same so just
by doing initiating a list where we
maintain the sequential order we are
going to achieve the same performance
that we needed to do 7 to 8 sales to do
all the functions there's a even shorter
step that is using Dunder magic so for
all our forecaster we have initiate uh
created few Dunder functions so that we
can do something like this so take log
multiplied by remove multiplied by Trend
forecaster what it is doing is it is
doing the exact screening the exact same
estimat object as we created earlier it
is selling taking uh saying first take a
log on the data set then do a remote
trans seon ID transformation pass this
transformation to the train forecaster
and the diverse also for the prediction
part this is not the only data magic
that we have we also have similar
transformation when we want to do handle
exogenous features when we want to do
multiple feature we can do column select
and that sort of thing we're not going
to go go into much details of that uh if
you go to our skm repository you can
find multiple examples for this or you
can reach out to us in Discord we will
be able to happy to help you with the
links now that we have this example one
thing that we that helped us here is
that we could identify that 12 was the
seasonal periodicity that it was varying
every 12 every 12 uh like after every 12
values the period seity is being receiv
to the original value not all the time
you will be able to do that so for
example you may not be clear so it may
be a quartly or monthly and you may not
be observing from the plot directly what
do you do
there for that we are going to take
benefit of another SK time component
which is parameter
estimation what we will do here is we
will go back to our Basics how do we get
a seasonality of a series we take we
make the series stationary first and
then from the ACF I find which are the
significant values that's exactly what
you are doing here first you are taking
a differen so by default it is taking
the first differences in different use
cases you can specify multiple legs
second on the deference object we are
going to fit theity SCF and find which
are the significant uh lag where it is
significant we are going to do a fit y
the original data set and the g fitted
pams method is going to give us the
actual fitted vies so as we can see here
SP soal short foral periodicity is 12
and SP significant is 12 and 11 few
forecasters that we support for example
mstl bats tbats they support to handle
multiple seasonality for their modeling
in that case SP significant is can be
used for today's session we are going to
be restricting ourselves to the use of
JP
so in this way you can use to
automatically identify what is the seity
of the data but this looks like much of
a uh Auto not automated use case manual
use case when you are doing an
interactive model you are using how can
you use it as part of a pipeline even
for automated process for a say for a
business continuously running a pipeline
the season is changing over time how do
you determine and automatically use it
for that we are going to use a plug-in
param
foraster this is combining the earlier
step with the previous pipeline here we
are going to first create a foraster
object this time we are going to use one
more foras object autoa this is on top
built on top of pmma
implementation then we are using the
same uh parameter estimation object that
we created earlier spsd and the for
Custer plugin param forecaster spst
forecaster what it is telling is first
do the parameter estimation on the
original data set then find the SP
parameter pass it to the forecaster
object how does it know what parameter
to pass in this particular case autoa
has the argument that has the name SP
and one of the fitted parameters from
the spst object is sp since it's a match
it's going to learn uh infert that
automatically and use it in case it was
not automatic say for example autoa had
different name say for example season
periodicity something like that we could
have used the keyword parameter params
and specify that up to ourselves in this
way when you specify and do a fit
predict call continuing our streamline
interface it is actually going to use
the 12 that was fitted before to see
that we can
get the foraster uncode object uh
property of the fitted pipeline object
and as we can see it's auta with with sp
sp equal to 12 12 are not passed by
manually but it is automatically
inferred as part of the fitting and
prediction process and this is a
particular example in very short of two
stage even if you have say for example
30 to 20 transformation steps first you
do a lot of data preprocessing then you
coming across this page it will still
going to work and you can combine it in
multiple ways uh in this particular case
we are lacking some features so if you
want to help us with some more
contribution this is welcome for example
adding some done magic given for plug-in
parameters and so
on okay so this is uh closure of the
second part of the pipeline flow so we
going now are coming to the third part
that is exogenous
predictions here we're going to cover
the case where we don't know the values
of the exogenous features for the
prediction Horizon this is actually
going to be the most common use case for
any business for example so say if you
want to do a price sales prediction you
may want to use price as your ex extra
feature but you may not know what is
going to be the price in future it is
not always something that you control it
may depend on dis Market factors so for
that sort of use case you don't know
price what do you do one option you Feit
a separate model for Price data that you
already have predict in future and those
predictions you pass those to the
original prediction model of sales and
use that that's exactly what we are
going to do here we are again going back
to the longly data set load the data
split as we did earlier again we will
going to fit the two models that we
fitted last time once's with X ones
without X and the second case here what
was the earlier case forecaster with X
we have renamed it to forecaster with X
known why we are going to fit one more
model for custom with X unknown in the
known case we are going to pass the
known data set so X train and X test in
both Feit and predict stage for the
unknown case we are not going to pass
the X test during the prediction and we
are going to see what happens if we try
to use the xtrain that was passed before
to predict for the future and use those
predictions for the uh prediction of Y
that's what uh we are going to do with
the forecast text composite object it is
one second part of our pipeline
components so we are creating a forecast
T object first we pass an algorithm
which is arima instance in this case
which is going to be used for y
prediction the second argument V Al
object uh in this particular case it is
different but if you want you can also
use the same object if you do not pass
anything that is you pass none it will
use the same for Custer by default as
the Y
foraster and if you want you can also
pass some other uh controls for example
you may choose to train the original
data set uh instead of using the
original data set during fitting you can
also use the prediction value for the
forecast at X during the fit stage this
is one of the very new introduction in
feature and that can be that behavior
can be controlled using a separate
parameter feed Behavior where you pass
use actual or use predictions anyway so
once you create the forecast Tex object
you will fit and predict using the exact
same interface that we are doing so far
and let's now see get the predictions
and their
plots right so we see the three lines
that we saw the Deep orange uh light
orange yellowish sort of and the green
and a final pinkish line that line is
the prediction that is coming from the
case where we use x only for the
training stage and for the prediction we
are using the already past X to predict
for future and to get this this is the
option that you can use for any real
life forecasting use case where you
don't have don't know X for future this
is uh covering our forecast X use case
so we are going have come to the last
section of the second
notebook here we we are going to see how
do we do parameter tuning and also we
are going to see a brief interview brief
example of uh back testing so what is
parameter tuning and when do we use it
so as we started the example uh this
notebook we started with auto ETS and we
said we are using the Hindman
implementation of Auto ATS so that it
can automatically infer whether to use
the additive or multiplicative model for
the era train Dam train Etc
components and obviously that's not for
auts other algorithms also have lots of
hyper parameters you may not always know
what hyper parameter to use in few cases
you may not even know what foraster to
use you may be choosing between Auto
arima auto ETS Theta maybe something
else how do you decide what to use we
are not going to cover the choice of
forecaster in this notebook that can be
done with Multiplex forecast another
capability of es time but here we are
going to see how do we determine the
optimal value of a parameter this we are
going to do with a slight generalization
of the grid search and random search
already part of uh escalar and we have
modified it so add the temporal
capabilities so first we are creating
the foraster object Auto ATS and this
time we are specifying Auto equal to
false so it doesn't do any automatic
inference on its own but also we are not
passing any of the values for eror train
Dam train seasonal Etc ourselves that we
we are going to find as part of the
tuning process itself so once we Lo the
data do a initial split to evaluate
later and we are going to create the
forecast object now we are going to
define the parameter grid these are all
the combinations that is going to be
defined then going to be tested for
example one particular instance is going
to be Auto ETS eror equal to add Trend
equal to add Dam Trend true seasonal add
sp4
another instance will be another
combination so in this particular case
so there are 2 4 and 1 three so 2 * 4 2
into 2 into 2 into 2 into three as many
models are going to be uh tested if we
use grid search if we use random search
obviously we can take it a bit down in
this particular it's a very small data
set so we are using grid search but in
most of the business use cases you
probably don't want grid search you will
probably want go for random search to
improve the performance
time okay once once you create the
parameter grid we need to find what is
bested to do that we need to create
cross validation splits for that we have
multiple splitter object which is once
again a first time object in uh SK time
and we're going to cover some part of in
the fourth notebook as well so in this
particular case when we say expanding
Windows splitter what we are saying is
create an initial split which has 12
data
points and the next six points use that
as a evaluation data set once you done
with that use the next split where you
add it by one more point that is being
identified by the step length argument
and evaluate it on the next six or next
six points and in this way you continue
so that's how we are plotting the C
splits that was actually created as part
of this splitter object and these are
the splits so as we can see there
are around 12 uh there are around 12 uh
splits each with different training data
uh training part and evaluation part
we're going to do cover all the splits
and see what algori uh on all the 48 use
cases that we possible ination of the
model that we see what works based on an
average on all these service bits to do
that we we need to start with creating
our object again we are importing from
forecasting grid CV and this time we are
using the model selection SubCom
of skm
forecasting then we pass the original
forecaster object that was initiated
without any hyper parameters Choice then
we pass the splits that we are going to
use third what are the possible options
for the parameters fourth how do we
choose what option is working better we
initiated a smap object earlier and smap
since it's a directly imported from SK
time itself it knows that SP would mean
lower is better but if you create your
own scoder you are free to do that you
may need to use the make forecasting
scoder function as part of the library
to make it uh to specify if better is
good or higher is better or lower is
better finally we specifying n job equal
to minus one to take into all the
processors in the not uh in the current
Compu environment again some part of it
is going to be covered in the fourth
notebook where it covered about uh
different paralyzation back end once we
initialize the grid search object we are
going to pass the training data which is
y train and we going to say okay train
and train for uh we are going to Target
is fit for next six
points this final object when it is
trained can be used directly for
prediction uh so we can as you can see
here when we call the dot predict method
we are seeing the predictions for the
next six
months and if we are curious about what
are the best hyper parameters are the
based codes we can access the different
attributes for example based pams is
going to tell you that this particular
choice of hyper parameters uh led to the
Bas SMF scod across splits as 0.08
967 and if you want to see the different
values in different splits that we can
also get from CV results attribute and
get in this
way so as a introduction to the tuning
and forecasting this is what all we are
going to cover in today's session now
all the pipelines that we have seen so
far are sequential like you do something
that argum the output of that is passed
on to only one next step what very often
that's not the case and to cover those
cases I will hand over to Benedict to
cover the graphical pip
comp thank you Anan um now we will talk
about a very very new feature um and
this feature are the graphical pipelines
as Anan
noted in a previous notebook we only
considered General sequential pipelines
but what are graphical pipelines to
understand graphical pipelines let us
shortly recap recap what sequential
pipelines are in a yeah in a more
abstract way so in a sequential pipeline
we have our input then this is passed to
the first step which might be a
pre-processing step then to the next
which might be an estimate estimation
step and then to the next perhaps
there's also postprocessing and then we
get the pr
prediction so we have here one data flow
and we execute step by step however in
general um many task are nonsequential
so there might be pre-processing steps
that are executed congruently we even
have multiple concurrent estimators that
then are
aggregated so there are many
non-sequential workflows and to solve
this there exists basically two
approaches in es time the first one is
to Nest sequential pipelines and the
second one is to use graphical
pipelines and this notebook is focusing
on on graphical Pipeline on how to use
them in SK time there is implemented a
generalized graphical pipeline graphical
pipeline here means that the different
steps may share the same predecessor so
for example estimator one and estimator
2 are congruently they are not dependent
on each other but they got the same
input so they got both input from
pre-processing
one furthermore there um one one EST one
estimate Ator um can also get um input
from different concurent predecessors
for example in that case estimator 2
would get the input from pre-processing
one and pre-processing two
so basically we here we have multiple
data flows the data flows can mer can
Branch but they can also
merge and if you are familiar with graph
Theory you probably
um has um have already show um seen that
this structure here is a directed e
graph and in in the following we will
focus on how we can yeah realize complex
forast in use cases with such graphical
pipeline um a side note here is the
graphical pipeline is still experimental
so yes there's a usual risk with such
features if you're using them however we
we would be happy very happy if you try
it out and if you provide us feedback on
the graphical pipeline so that we can
improve this
feature now let us shortly cons um take
a look on the use case we want to focus
in in this
notebook basically we also we use again
the long lay data set and in this case
we would like to um forecast the
inflation and for that we want to use
different exogeneous features that we
require to be for that have to be
forecasted these exogeneous features are
the gross domestic product the real DPI
and the unemployment rate for these
different yeah
um time series we have different
pre-processing and different forecasters
and these different forecaster may use
as exogeneous features the the
forecaster data
so um this yeah this use case we will
Implement um in a few minutes using the
graphical pipeline but first we have to
learn how we can create a graphical
Pipeline and basically there are two
approaches for creating them the first
one is to pass all steps during
initialization and the second one is to
use an add step method during
initialization you would create the
pipeline object and then pass a list of
steps important here is that the the the
list of steps that each step is
specified by a
dictionary having at least the keywords
SK object name and address SK object is
the SK type Transformer forecaster
classifier or so um yeah that you would
like to
add then you have to name the this step
you have to name the step explicitly
because we can add a Transformer
forecaster multiple times to the
pipeline and the pipeline itself would
keep track of this of the identity and
would be used in the same
instance and then in the end we have
also here an edes parameter which gets
uh as
value and here the X means that the X
input of the differenti should be the Y
input of the pipeline
itself um using the ad step is basically
the same so for each step you would call
um add step on the pipeline itself this
returns a new Pipeline with the added
added
step and the the minimal um parameter
set would be the SK object the name and
the
edges beside that there exists further
AR um further further parameters the
most important one are qu um and Method
method with method you can specify the
method that should be called on the es
object here in that case on the
differen and this is is required if you
want to control this for example if you
want to reverse the differentiation
after a forecast you have
to um to specify here method equals
inverse transform in contrast to
sequential pipelines this is not
inferable for for graphical
pipelines and CS uh is a dictionary
specific additional keywords that can be
passed to the ESC time object so key um
um um um key messages are here that
there are two ways to construct a
graphical pipeline either during
initialization or using the ad step in
the following when we implement this
more complex example I I explained you
previously we will stick with the head
step
notation okay now let us create this
pipeline first we we create our pipeline
object by just calling pipeline without
specifying any steps now we want to add
the DC analyzer and the scaler so we add
the
preprocessing and we do this by calling
the at step method of the
pipeline first we pass here the the
standard scaler and we use here the
tablea to serus adapter so that the SK
learn um Transformer is directly
adaptable to time series we name it
scaler and here we specify the edges so
the X input of the scalar is the
unemployment column of the X input of
the pipeline if you have here in the
value string two underscores it means
that you want to select a
column here in the DC analyzer Ian the
the Second Step there is a DC signaler
we added we call the step DC analyzer
and here the X input of the DC analyzer
would be the columns here we select two
columns real GDP and real
DPI okay now we have added the DC
signaler and the scaler now let us go on
and add the forecaster for the G GTP and
the
DPI and here we call make reduction so
that the SK learn rich regressor is
applicable to time series we name the
first one here forecasted GTP and as
edes we specify that the Y input which
in a forecaster is the time series you
want to forecast is the dcal um the
output of the D calized and more
specifically we want the real GDP column
of the D analyzer
output um the forecaster for the DPI is
then is also a regressor and here we
name it forecaster DPI and here we
specify as the time series that should
be forecasted the the time series the
output column real DPI of the DC
analyzer which is the predecessor in the
pipeline okay now we have added the DC
signaler the scaler the forecast the GDP
and and the forecast at DPI now we want
to add the forecast of the unemployment
rate the forecast of the unemployment
rate depends as exogeneous features on
the forecast at DPI and the forecast at
GDP and tries to forecast the scaled
unemployment rate so again we add a rich
regressor name provide a name and now
the Y times y input of the rich
forecaster is the unemployment column of
the scala's output specified here um s x
input so as exogeneous features for the
rich reg regressor we want to use the
forecast the output of the forecast GDP
and the forecaster
DPI and here we are
using we are passing these both param
and these these we specify here a list
and the list is implicitly using a
feature Union
here and now we have added a deionizer
scaler these for and these three
forecasters and now we only have to add
our final
forecaster and we use again a wi
regressor um provide forecaster
inflation as a name and here we specify
again our our input edges so the ex
input of the inflation forecaster would
be the forecasted DPI and forecasted
unemployment rate and the time series
you would like to forecast is the
inflation
rate um and now we can just load our
data here we specify our X and our Y
data we specify our forecasting Horizon
and then perform our temporal train test
split as Anan shown has shown here is
our exrain data and now we can can just
call pipe fit and then pipe predict and
we get our prediction so basically we
have here again the same interface as
for all other for coers or for
all yeah for all other pipelines
important to note here is that instead
of the and that the pipeline itself is
generalized so if you would have added a
classifier instead of a forecaster then
it would
automatically um um Rec um recognize
that this and the predict signature
would be um of the of a classifier would
be automatically um
supported okay now you might ask how
does the graphical pipeline compare to a
sequential pipeline so let therefore let
us try to imple um Implement a
simplified version of the above example
since the above example is not re really
implemented implementable using just
sequential pipelines using and to do
this um we have here um our our figure
how the sequential um how our final
pipeline looks like should look like and
now we have to figure out sequential sub
pipelines that we can create and for
example we
can um put UMR for transform Target
forecaster for their GDP using a DC
analyzer as per processing the same for
DPI and the unemployment trate then we
can do a column or sample forecaster to
combine each of these three forecasting
pipelines and then we can use a
forecaster X so that then which where
the column assemble forecaster X is
forecasting the x value and then we can
specify a forecaster for why and this
would provide also a forecaster so here
are again these steps and here is the
corresponding code where we are
constructing the different forecasting
pipelines I will not dive into
it um if you're taking a look into our
pataa Park Workshop of this year then
you can see more details on
it
and in this pipeline we can again call
fit we can again call predict get a
prediction and if we take a look into
the get params keys of this nested
sequential pipeline then we see here
very very long Keys this is caused
because we are using so much nesting and
imagine if you would like
to hyper par hyper tune um yeah tune the
alpha hyper parameter of your
of of this um um of this estimator then
you have to use very long shes for for
the grid search actually there is a new
feature like that so if Alpha would be
unique you can just write Alpha as long
as you're using psychic Bas 0.6.1 or
higher oh nice I wasn't aware of that
thank you for this remark
F okay so wrapping up what are the
advantage of sequential pipelines and
graphical pipelines um advantages of the
sequential pipeline are that sequential
pipelines are um very easy to use very
easy to to build and very well suited
for simple simpler um yeah use
cases um they are automatically applying
inverse operation in contrast to the
graphical Pipeline and they are a major
Feature Feature and they are stable so
the graphical pipeline in contrast is
still um in an experimental
status however the graphical pipeline
enables you to implement very very
complex pipelines um without requiring
nesting um the parameter structure would
be far more easier than of the
sequential pipeline in the above
example and you only have to track one
estimator compared to the m
sequential pipelines and the sequential
pipeline
example so that was about the graphical
pipeline feature which it was recently
added and now fanss will talk um tell
you about other new features of the past
two years in yes so this is going to be
a sequence of very short lightning talks
on various topics to Big topics Advanced
modeling going to show some parallelism
features parallel broadcasting to
hierarchic in multivariate data
probabilistic distributional forecasts
composable time series classification
regressors
benchmarking and then second batch of
features Marketplace and deployment
features we have seen already estimator
search in some parts estimator tax
blueprint fitted estimated serialization
and ml flow integration and I fear these
90 minutes are non-negotiables will try
to be Swift now uh first feature
parallelism for multivariate in
hierarchical broadcasting we have prev
prly seen already if you're applying a
univariate forecaster to multivariate
data it will
automatically uh broadcast to the
columns so multiple models of the same
kind are fited to the columns we've seen
it in the first part now you can
parallelize that with any backend that
is integrated in the parallelization
backend abstraction framework in SK Time
by using the set config so every psychic
base based estimator object has a config
interface and a set config interface for
parallelization of broadcasting this is
only for broadcasting is using the
backend parallel and backend parallel
params keys in the backend parallel
parameter you can select multiple
parallelization backends consult the set
config do string for it lowkey is drop
lips lowkey back end and drop Li as the
back endend paration back end of SK time
here parameters here to parallel are
passed by the back and parallel params
if you then scroll down the code Remains
the Same you need to set the config
before you fit and before you predict
and the effect of it is that the code is
then distributed to the workers or using
the parallelization back end the same
for hierarchical data which we have not
seen but let me quickly explain
hierarchical data that is if you have in
one data set multiple observations
across hierarchy level so let's say
we're observing sales of Home Appliances
in food preparation food preservation
product line and different product group
so total sales by product group and
there could be hundreds and thousands of
product groups so it's it's a typical
parallelization case for the for your
base uh Baseline estimators so let's
scroll down SK time supports
hierarchical data if you have seen that
the pandas with multi-index product line
product groups so hierarchy levels are
the first multi-index levels in the if
you represented by data frame the time
is the last level and you can use the
forecasting interface with this kind of
data the same way as he would use it
with a single time series and it will
predict for a for a non-h hierarchical
model it will apply the forecaster per
uh per index per in per hierarchy level
so let's scroll down a
bit because of time so syntax is very
much the same fit and predict forecasts
are being produced for product groups of
course if you have a genuinely
hierarchical forecaster which we will
not have time to get into today then uh
hierarchical a ver forecast is generated
if it's not then you have the same
behavior as in variable broadcasting
same Syntax for parallelization Via set
config so this applies to both variables
and hierarchy levels let's move down so
next feature
vignette um well this works also for
grid search in estimators you will have
the backend and backend params um
estimator keys if they're if they
integrated so it's the same string for
paralyzation back and same way to pass
parameters okay probabilistic
forecasting we have seen in the first uh
in in a forecasting notebook the predict
interval method so this produces
interval predictions with a data frame
with a a column multi-index with for
coverage and lower upper there's a few
other methods as well so predict
quantiles predict variance and predict
proper we have changed how predict
proper works in the recent year can we
scroll down to that
please the predict proper method now
returns a first class citizen name the
distribution object so probability
distribution of tabular form are now
also first class citizens in SK time
there's also refactoring effort ongoing
with skap Pro that's a that's an
extension to psyit learn where
regression estimators can also make
probabilistic predictions or interval
predictions now these distributions have
tax as any first class object in SK time
so it has a
potential uh so distribution type and
further information about the
distribution it has its own methods also
a unified interface as skarn like such
as sample you can sample from
distributions for instance if you need
it for Monte Carlo uh business the
distribution that's produced you can
always s from it U by default for most
estimators it's a normal distribution
distributions have a pandas like
interface with index columns and lock
and iog so you can use lock and iog to
subset the distribution it Al you can
also have access to distribution
defining functions like PDF or CDF PDF
if it is defined and it works seamlessly
with probabilistic metric so if you want
to evaluate a forecaster for instance
via the conrank probability score you
construct it again a first class object
and compare it against the actuals so
note that the second AR argument here of
course not a pus data frame but a pus
like distribution
object all right moving on so more about
this Pi data Amsterdam moving on if you
do time series classification or time
series regression you will be aware that
your estimators are often highly
composite so many classifiers or
regressors they're based on time series
distances time series alignment
algorithms which in turn are again based
on dist Vector distances so distances on
vectors in the real numbers like normal
data sets one example would be one
nearest neighbors using Dynamic time
warping distance which internally use
the Movis distance now the change the
the re architecting that has occurred
over the last years makes all of these
objects first class citizens based on um
a psychic base so all of these objects
now have their type and they can be
composed and they work with get parum so
if you go from bottom to top here we're
building a k neighbors time series
classifier that uses skarn KNN then
we're transforming an alignment
algorithm to a distance the alignment
algorithm comes from the alignment
Library DTW Python and internally it
uses the distance from scipi and the
dependencies are of course separated
here and all of these components are
individual objects if you look at the
get parms or the estimator structure it
works like esarn you can now com you can
now tune or compose
all of these objects separately we look
at the object types they are Transformer
panel for time series distances and
kernels aligner for Al time series
aligners transformer pairwise for Vector
distances and of course Transformer are
the Transformers and you can also
combine all of them via dund magic where
it makes sense or you can combine
distances to more distances many of
these distances are compositors and all
estimators here lists all the distances
with the type so there's fewer kernels
than distances but you can Al turn
kernels and distances or distances to
kernels alignment algorithms they're
less but many of these classes they
cover many options in Upstream
packages okay benchmarking only going to
brush through at very quickly in the
benchmarking module it's currently very
much still a work in progress can Define
benchmarking experiments adding
estimators and adding tasks for
forecasting for instance this would be
forecasters the tasks would be
uh back testing schemas so cross
validation objects and data loaders and
scorers adding the task adding the
estimator then running the experiment
storing the results on the hard drive or
in memory is is what this module does
still work in progress but I think it's
a very interesting use case very
interesting area so contributions here
appreciated the tutorial is also in Pyon
prag moving on to Marketplace and
deployment featur of finding estimators
there's by now hundreds of objects
estimators metrics and otherwise of
different types in esate times have
introduced a typing system and a system
for estimator search which allows you to
list estimators by type and property to
list all forecasters use all estimators
with the forecaster type we have seen
this but this works for any other type
that is supported by SK SK time for
instance the splitter type that's
splitter all types are listed in the
registry module accessible to the
registry module all objects are Tagged
so classes have tags and object
instances have tags for instance the
object type tells you of the type
there's a lot of types tags that are
interesting to the user object tags can
depend on object parameters but they
will not depend on object state so here
you have tags for instance about
capability of making insample forecasts
and you can produce now tables using
these tags using estimator that might be
useful for search so list all
forecasters with whether this forecaster
has the capability of insample forecast
or making probabilistic predictions you
can also use the utility to filter of
course you could filter directly via the
data frame here but it's also a
convenience function with the all
estimators there's a similar utility
called all tags which allows you to list
all available tags with an explanation
what the tag actually means for a given
object type this is very much also aod
topic so we want to also specify scope
across packages possibly second and
third party packages allow also our
users to have access to this uh search
functionality across their own packages
or across multiple packages in the in
the in the ecosystem the estimator
overview is also a bit outdated so we
would like to update that if you're a
frontend developer please make yourself
known at the exit now sharing Blueprints
and models is also possible
if you're for instance sharing it inside
your deployment system or storing models
fitted models or blueprints this works
similarly but slightly differently can
all it's also useful for research
reproducibility so let's suppose we want
to share the model blin for this
pipeline well the serialized object is
simply the string now we need to know we
need something that reconstructs the
object from the string and that's a
method called craft in registry module
so if you want to serialize a blueprint
simply U serialize the string and store
the environment with Pip
freeze uh then on the receiving end you
can create an environment from the PIP
freeze and restore the estimator with
the craft utility there's further
supportive utilities so before you
construct the estimator you can get a
more coar list of dependencies which is
uh less specific than a pip freeze this
is the depth utility it will list the
dependencies that are specified by the
individual estimator we specify
dependencies on individual estimator
basis for fitted estimators for
Persistence of fitted models all first
class objects have the save method this
defaults to pickle but special
specialized
serialization uh logic can be
implemented for things like neural
networks so if you use object. save it
will provide you a serialized object you
can save to a path or you can save to a
string uh sorry you can save to a path
or you can save to memory if you have
provide no argument it protes a
serialized in memory object from the
base module the load then so it's not a
method of a class but it's a loose
method it also constructs it also
retrieves the serializes the fitted
object which you then can use for
prediction all right ml flow I'm going
to skip this exists so ml flavor is the
package
where you can get the MLF flow
integration from or of course from SK
time also has an MLF flow subm module
all right so wrapping up thank you very
much we have seen today forecasting the
new updated interface pipelines
introduction graphical pipeline in
advanced modeling with in parallelism
probabilistic forecasts composable time
Ser classification benchmarking
Marketplace features estimator search
psychic based interface and just to
reiterate let's go to the outro SK time
is not just a package ecosystem it is
actually a Vibrant Community we are
openly governed we invite you all to
contribute join our
Discord uh look at our good first issues
this further material official SK time
tutorial on the main repository or
vision is to be open source permissive
license free to use to remain openly and
transparently governed be friendly
responsive inclusive we have a mentoring
program so there's a link to the
mentoring program here if you would like
to be mentored to make your first open
source contribution or to be mentored in
contributing to SK time specifically
there's a form you can fill out we have
uh usually four uh four opportunities in
the year to start mentoring cohorts in
the summer we tend to have internships
and project opportunities you can also
join our Discord follow us on LinkedIn
for news on events like developer
Sprints we have uh and of course stars
on GitHub or better even donate to help
us keep SK time running thank you very
much for your attention and hope to see
you as contributors or on Discord say
hello open a uh good first issue pull
request and looking forward to see you
all any further questions Beyond this
feel free to ask on the Discord help
desk Channel or in GitHub discussions
I suppose we're out of time
now hello yes uh thank you so much for
your presentation it was fantastic um
yeah if uh I think you already posted
your slides in Discord so thank you for
doing that and uh yeah we appreciate
it thank you all and thank you benedict
on bu it's always a pleasure to work
with
you thank you also for my
side thank you and credits we should
scroll down to the credits for all
contributors SK time is a project which
has by now multiple 100 contributors we
use all contribution all contributors
for
contribution assignment this can also
include non- quote contribution such as
planning project management event
management